we're told the graph of the function f
of X is equal to x squared we see it
right over here in gray is shown in the
grid below graph the function G of X is
equal to X minus 2 squared minus 4 in
the interactive graph and this is from
the shifting functions exercise on Khan
Academy and we can see we can change we
can change the we can change the graph
of G of X but let's see we want to graph
it properly so let's see how they relate
well let's think about a few things
let's first just make G of X completely
overlap well actually that's completely
easier said than okay there you go now
they're completely overlapping and let's
see how they're different well G of X if
you look at what's going on here instead
of having an x squared we have an X
minus 2 squared so one way to think
about it is when x is 0 you have 0
squared is equal to 0 but how do you get
0 here well X has got to be equal to 2 2
minus 2 squared is 0 squared if we don't
look at the negative 4 just yet and so
we would want to shift this graph over 2
to the right this is essentially how
much do we shift to the right it's
sometimes a little bit counterintuitive
that we have a negative there because
you might say well negative that makes
me think that I want to shift to the
left but you don't have to remind
yourself is like well okay for the
original graph when it was just x
squared to get to get the 0 squared I
just have to put x equals 0 now to get a
0 squared I have to put in a 2 so this
is actually shifting the graph to the
right and so what do we do with this
negative 4 well this is a little bit
more intuitive or at least for me when I
first learned it this literally will
just shift the graph down whatever your
value is of X minus 2 squared it's going
to shift it down by 4 so what we want to
do is just shift both of these points
down by 4 so this is going to go from 9
this is going to go from the coordinate
5 comma 9 to 5 comma 4 go down for 5
comma 5 and it's going to go from 2
comma 0 to 2 comma negative 4 2 comma
negative 4 did I do that right
I think that
is I think that's right what essentially
what we have going on is G of X is f of
X shifted to to the right and four down
two to the right and four down and
notice if you look at the vertex here we
shifted two to the right and four down
and I and I shifted this one also this
one also I shifted two to the right and
four down and there you have it we have
we have we have graphed G of X which is
a shifted version of f of X